[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins
we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
happy day after hearing
i guess
happy
after seeing what we saw
last night
hearing with some of the clips we're
gonna go through all the clips today
here's the time eclipse to go dude
thanks for joining us last night for the
january 6th select hearing
our special broadcast with midas touch
on the mind touch facebook page and
their youtube channel thanks for all
that had joined and watched the coverage
of the january 6 select committee
laying out their evidence
a lot of significant points
not just from the witnesses one of the
things i thought was most significant
and i'm gonna bring it up and i'm gonna
keep bringing it up
and liz cheney
outed scott perry
that he was
hoping for a pardon
you know what really is funny
there's a guy down in florida joel
greenberg
who is uh
who is pled guilty to federal charges
you know he's matt gatz's buddy you know
who this guy is he's the one that his
venmo friend where they were venmoing
money back and forth for drugs and
hookers and underage women and you know
hiding it as ice cream and things
joe greenberg
was trying to get a pardon as well and
now he's under federal indictment he's
pled guilty to federal charges
he even used stodger rohn
as his way to
petition to campaign for a pardon
and here we have scott perry what i want
to know
what i want to know other than scott
perry who were the [ __ ] members of
congress that were in the pardon line
that's right it seems like there was a
line at the white house for a [ __ ]
pardon for all the crimes that they had
committed
we see the proud boys the oath keepers
charged with seditious conspiracy
is there members of congress hmm
very funny we've been talking about this
for a while folks
i think when liz cheney
says scott perry's name and says that
there's other members of congress
that were were humping for pardons
i think we're gonna see an expulsion
list
is what we're gonna see
now benny thompson the other day said
there will be consequences
from from the evidence that has been
gathered by the january 6th select
committee
there are things that they will put
forward i believe one of those things is
to bar donald trump from ever running
for public office federal public office
again
it seems like that's where we're headed
here
that's why these republicans are all
like oh yeah sure i'd vote for him
because they know that you're not going
to be able to vote for him on a [ __ ]
ballot
the other thing that i think is
significant
that could be a potential consequence of
the evidence that the january 6 select
committee has gathered up and we will
see over these hearings and we're going
to follow every single one of them we're
going to stream every single last one of
them
so make sure you join us
on all these hearings
you know i think i think i'll go ahead
and put out a a schedule today and keep
retweeting that schedule so you guys
have it maybe we'll make it into a
graphic so you can
spread it around the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends
but we will we will gabble in and gabble
out and we will do commentary before and
after just like we did last night but i
think
the list
of the members of congress who went
to donald trump and who campaigned for
pardons to the white house
well i think that would make a good
expulsion list
especially since the only time you
really
campaign for a pardon is when you
[ __ ] need one
what the [ __ ] would you need a pardon
for
if you didn't commit
sedition
tell me
give me an example of what you would
need a pardon for
we don't even know if there's such thing
as a preemptive pardon in the first
place really
of a crime that you don't even know is
if it is a crime or it isn't a crime
there's preemptive prosecutions
when there's investigations
but you're talking about days think
about this for a second jared kushner in
the testimony said he was pushing for
pardons so he was humping for pardons in
those last days i don't know who for
but he was solely concentrated on
pardons
but in the remaining days of his
presidency
he was focused on pardons
this is before anyone really gathered
the evidence
that there would be members of congress
that would be
deep in this conspiracy i was only weeks
later
into the impeachment trial that we found
that out i mean there were hints of it
there were parts of the media that were
saying yes there were members of
congress giving tours of the capitol
but it was unclear who it was lauren
bobert
i mean we know we know who the fascists
are it's easy to see who the fascists
are they love nick fuentes
you know these nick fuentes types
marjorie taylor green paul goes our
mo brooks annie biggs lauren bober jim
jordan matt gatz these american first
types
anyone who types out the words america
first and thinks it's a good thing
those are the seditious ones
they're easy to spot
they're ron desantis let's go brandon
nazis
it's not hard to figure this out
it really isn't
but we have to give the evidence to the
american people the other thing i think
is very significant and we brought it up
in the after show
with our panel
and i think it was michael popock who
posed the question
of why
did the january 6 select committee show
the ivanka tape
in the very beginning section
at the very first hearing
and some said it was to
give grandpa poopypants
the fright of his life
which i think that's true i think
there's some truth and that
donald trump's ego lives in ivanka
trump's brawl
i mean
doubt me
he's absolutely obsessed with ivanka
it's weird it's gross
you've seen the evidence throughout the
years
so yeah maybe maybe liz cheney and the
january 6 select committee were doing it
as a dig
but i think the video beforehand was
significant
and the the video before the ivanka
video was bill barr himself saying that
the big lie was all a bunch of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it was a big [ __ ] lie it was all
horseshit and trump knew it was [ __ ]
horseshit he'd had three meetings that
he could quote unquote recall
that's meaning that's what was recorded
in his official records
that's what he means by that when bill
barr says
the three times that i can recall those
are the three times that are in official
notes so that's what he has to recall
under oath
so that he does not perturb himself
because there's records
and they have those records i'm sure
of those count three conversations that
bill barr had with donald trump
but bill barr said in his testimony to
the select committee it is a bunch of
horse [ __ ] and i told him so that it's
all [ __ ] [ __ ]
and ivanka trump in the following clip
which i'm sure we're gonna see more of
this testimony i don't think we're just
gonna get those two little 30-second
snippets from bill barr and ivanka trump
i think that's the most damning evidence
to the big lie
and that's the most important part
is the big lie think about it without
the lie without the lie
what the [ __ ] does it matter
if there is no lie and no one believes
the nonsense
that donald trump somehow got the
election stolen away from him there's no
insurrection
there's no reason to commit sedition
other than you want a fascist state
but it all falls apart for normal
americans
it all falls apart for people who don't
pay attention to politics if the
attorney general who donald trump loved
and and his daughter
who everyone knows he loves her i mean
let's face it if he if she wasn't his
daughter he'd be [ __ ] her
he said it in so many words
he trusted her so much that he had her
in the white house with him
one of his most trusted advisors
and most important piece of
offspring eye candy it's really weird
it's [ __ ] weird
but listen
this idea that bill barr
was telling donald trump three different
times you're full of [ __ ] [ __ ]
and ivanka's trump saying i believe bill
barr
i think donald trump is full of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
her admitting it under oath folks
i think the significant of that
the significance of that
is to tear down the big lie
and to make sure people know that behind
closed doors these people aren't saying
what they're saying in [ __ ] public
hell yeah there's a chance well god damn
there's a chance that joe biden
blew the hunter buttons laptop
give me a [ __ ] break
it's all [ __ ] nonsense it's all
dribble
every last single bit of the big lie is
[ __ ] [ __ ] now we all know that
because we watched as rudy giuliani told
a federal judge
and i'm sure they're gonna play that
tape i'm almost positive when they get
to the rudy giuliani part of the
hearings which they will they'll
probably play where he farted on jenna
ellis
i i wouldn't imagine why they wouldn't i
mean why wouldn't you play the part
where he farts on jenna ellis that's one
of the best [ __ ] parts
also the the
the
the four seasons
press conference that four seasons
landscaping
they have to play that part
but when they get to the rudy giuliani
part of the hearing they will play the
tape where rudy giuliani had to tell a
judge no
we are not claiming there's fraud
because there was no evidence you can't
go to court and present a case to a
judge of fraud when you don't have
evidence of it
the judge will [ __ ]
well they'll take away your law license
rudy giuliani
if you lie
it's really [ __ ] dumb
but i put together the two clips
a bill bar and ivanka trump and i put
him on our our twitter page go over to
our twitter page and follow at tony
michael's pod you will see that at the
very top of the page
and i said show this to your uncle earl
and your aunt edna
show it to him show it to your uncle
earl and your aunt edna
show them that his daughter the one that
you think's great and fantastic because
he loves her boobs
like literally that's why they like her
these manga types they like her because
trump thinks she's hot
it's super [ __ ] weird
it's
how in the i mean it's
i
i digress there
oh [ __ ]
yeah
but just show them
that trump's
favorite child trump's favorite person
in the entire world i mean other than
himself that's what karen agnipolo said
last night
in the follow-up commentary to the
hearing she had mentioned that that this
this is his favorite person in the
entire world other than himself i think
it was karen either that or it might
have been lee mcgowan politics girl
it's hard to remember there was a lot of
commentary last night you guys should go
watch that by the way it's over on midas
touch youtube channel um maybe maybe
i'll convince um
someone to and maybe we'll do it maybe
i'll cut it up just the commentary and
put it out on the youtubes so you guys
can just go watch the commentary if you
just want to watch the commentary
because it was great the the commentary
before was fantastic um we had a little
ditty in between and the 10-minute break
we brought in karen ignifullo and texas
paul and then we had um we had david
bender we had pop we had karen agnipolo
we had texas paul we had lee mcgowan
politics girl we had gabe sanchez
at the end and we had the mizellas
brothers don't forget the myzellas
brothers we had that part of the
of the commentary
the midas touch podcast joined us at
after the hearing so go check all that
out go check out that commentary and
again maybe we'll cut it up and we'll
send out a link on twitter or something
but in that commentary we talked about
ivanka trump and someone said that
ivanka trump
is his favorite person in the world and
here she is
siding with bill barr who said the words
it was all
[ __ ]
and i think that's the most important
part folks
i think that's the most important part
that's why they played in the beginning
because as karen agnivolo says a
prosecutor always leads with their best
evidence
and the best evidence is is that even
the people who are spreading the big lie
know it's a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's all horse [ __ ]
it is a lie
and if we can just get a few just a
handful it doesn't need to be a lot
just a few people
to finally admit
yeah okay i was just kidding this whole
time i was just being a sycophant
it was all it's all [ __ ]
if we can just get a few and a few to
admit that these members of congress who
tried to commit sedition inside our
[ __ ] house now the senate is a
totally different chamber so that's
going to be a different case for
expulsion over there
but in the house
where they can expel their own members
and they have before don't let anyone
spread a lie about that it is possible
they can do it
and i believe they will
when there's a list of congress congress
people
who participated in sedition and they're
expelled from expelled from congress
listen
if you don't think that's a consequence
from the january six select committee
because the slot committee can't bring
criminal charges
they don't have the ability to
criminally charge someone now they can
give a referral we've seen that with
steve bannon peter navarro and others
with their contempt
they can give a referral
but they cannot they cannot
charge someone with a crime
but they can however
they can however
expel members
and i believe that's where they're going
i believe that's what benny thompson's
idea is
and i think darth vader jr liz cheney
is ready
as texas paul says to stick the knife in
and break it off
stick around right after the break we
will go through the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends don't go anywhere
stick around right after these messages
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
with the [ __ ] list roundup
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime please donate now
because those trump supporters you just
saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to
the show
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you very much
for being here
you know um today we're not gonna have
gabe sanchez with us i know that's uh
disappointing to um to everybody
um
gabe gabe is out having fun he had a
scheduled event
um for for his friend who is getting
married
um it's been on the books for a while he
actually last night uh believe it or not
now he was joining us um from a party
that he was at um so i i want to thank
gabe sanchez our co-host and executive
producer i i hope i i tried to get him
to
agree that he would have joined us at
least from his cell phone today so you
all could thank him in person from the
chat um he did a great job for the first
hearing and again he's going to continue
to do a great job he was actually doing
some graphics on the fly last night
as he was paying attention to um
his
his commitment to his event and the
hearing as well so i want to thank gabe
sanchez
for doing all the hard work here at the
tony michaels podcast but also on the
hearing last night it was a great
success we had i i don't know i i think
i think their total is
over 150 000 views so far a lot of
people watch it so if anyone out there
says oh no one was watching the hearing
no one watch that [ __ ] yeah a lot of
people watched it
a lot of people watched it
a [ __ ] ton of people watched that
hearing last night and it's up to us to
spread these clips around
right
we have to spread these clips around and
if you see a good one don't hesitate to
keep resharing it when someone puts
these clips together that might click
with someone it might get in front of
eyes of someone
who believes something like the big lie
because their ego's getting in the way
because they just needs that extra push
for someone else because
that's what i frankly think that they
were trying to do with that very first
part with bill barr and ivanka trump
clips of their testimony was to to show
america that you're believing [ __ ]
it's complete utter [ __ ] dribble it's
not real the [ __ ] that you're believing
about the election yes
yes
81 million people didn't vote for joe
biden
because a lot of those 81 million people
voted against donald trump
and that's why the big lie can live
because that's true
there are plenty of people out there in
that 81 million that don't like joe
biden
they just knew the risk if donald trump
was the president again
they seen it in 2020 with the
coronavirus with the pandemic and how he
handled it
it wasn't rocket science so which one
was the better choice
it wasn't jesus christ it could have
been [ __ ] mickey mouse for crying out
loud
but that's why the big lie can live
it's because there are people out there
that didn't exactly vote for joe biden
they voted against donald trump
there are a lot of americans there are a
lot of voters out there that use their
ballot against something and there's
nothing wrong with that that is your
right as an american to use your vote to
vote against something
now is that the right way or the
appropriate way
you know what we never will tell only
history will tell us
what we did right or wrong but we can't
change it
we can only move forward
and we can only learn
from the [ __ ] that we've done
so here's what i'll tell
you teach folks even the people who
agree with you
even the people who voted for biden
because they know trump is bad and they
wouldn't vote for trump again
give them the opportunity to see these
clips because they're not all americans
aren't gonna watch these hearings gavel
to gavel they're not going to and even
us doing a compelling commentary before
in the middle and after may not get as
many eyes as we need on the entire
hearing itself i didn't watch a single
god damn minute of johnny depth and
amber heard but i saw a few clips that
leaked through on my social media
but that's what we have to do
that's what we have to do that is now
our duty as america
and then as as americans and
pro-democracy americans
is to show people what they're saying
and yes
in the in the age that we live in we
live in thirty second clips
we live in thirty second sound bites
we live in reality tv
universe
we literally are at the intersection of
wrestlemania and real life
but we can use that truth
for our gain
and our gain is to preserve democracy
that is our goal here
i don't believe that democracy is
perfect i don't believe that democracy
is easy it's actually the opposite
democracy is [ __ ] difficult it is
really hard to get a lot of people to
agree on something
it's really [ __ ] difficult folks and
at this time and then this age if that
doesn't show through i don't know what
will prove it to you with social media
that it is super difficult to get
everyone to agree on the same thing but
that's the beauty of democracy
that's the beauty of it is we don't have
to agree but listen that's why they love
autocracy that's why these fascists
that's why these very scared
white privileged folks out there
are still clinging on to the big lie
because they don't want equality they
don't want equity because they fee the
the mindset of the privileged is that
equality equals oppression
it doesn't but that's what that's their
mindset
so keep pushing share those clips around
and i don't just mean share them on
social media
when you're with your when i said show
this to your your uncle earl and your
aunt edna i literally mean go to their
house get your [ __ ] cell phone out
and play that goddamn video a couple
times in front of their face i don't
mean send it to their email box
make set them down and make them watch
that [ __ ]
if you have someone
who you know is not is is not dumb if
you know it's not it it is is
is usually not gullible
and duped very easy but they've been
duped by the big lie
go show them that video go show them
it's it's at the top it's at the top of
our twitter
at tony michael's bod
i penned it and i'll keep it pen for a
while
and i'll keep spreading it around go
show that video
it's just a short clip it's like i own
40 seconds something like that well
where i'm gonna play it i'm gonna play
it here right right now on when we surf
the tweety tweets in the trendy trend
this is one of the first things i'm
gonna play
but go show that clip that is that is
very important
and i know why it's important
it's it's just what karen agnivolo
alluded to in our commentary after the
hearing she said a prosecutor always
leads with their best evidence
and the best evidence for sedition here
is that they knew
they knew that he had lost he knew he
had lost and the only way to retain
power was to steal our vote away from us
at any cost
and any cost
even expulsion even to the degree where
members of congress were lining up for
[ __ ] pardons
at any cost
they would
take to ensure
that donald trump remained in power
and i'm sure
that we can surmise about the reason but
does it really matter
does it really matter the reason
it shouldn't matter to your uncle earl
and your aunt edna
that they've been spot and sold a lie
maybe they've mortgaged their house to
give donald trump money based on this
[ __ ] [ __ ] lie that his daughter
even admits
under oath in testimony that yes what
bill barr says
is true and bill barr says it's a bunch
of [ __ ] so let's get to it let's go
through the videos let's surf the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends
start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
so
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome welcome back to
the show thanks for joining us we have
reached the part of the show where we
go through the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends we surf
twitter
through the shitless roundup and we got
a lot of stuff to get to there's a lot
of video from last night but the one
that i want to show you
[Music]
is this one right here
this is the main one here it is
i said show this to your uncle earl and
your aunt edna
uh let me let me make this a little
bigger here because this is important
now what you're seeing here
is bill barr
the attorney general the former attorney
general of the united states
now i'm sure this is a very long video
in other words this is just a small clip
of the video but what you're going to
hear him say here is how many times he
met with the president again like i said
before he says as i recall
meaning in his official notes there was
three conversations
that his official note shows that he met
with donald trump about this subject
now why is that important because
there's probably more meetings they just
weren't officially recorded either that
or
bill barr and donald trump dined on the
notes that they were the paper that the
notes were written on we know they ate
notes and flush notes down the toilet
burned them shredded them so these are
the notes that existed was these three
meetings
with bill barr and donald trump
but bill barr goes on to describe
the information that was exchanged in
the meeting and what he's talking about
is the conspiracy theories
the nonsense that somehow there was
fraud because what donald trump was
trying to do was to get the doj to come
out and say there was fraud
and they wouldn't bilbar wouldn't
and then jeffrey clark wouldn't
and we're gonna see we're going to see
that these
excuse me donna you wouldn't
we're going to see that these [ __ ]
were committing sedition inside the doj
just like pope just described on the
show the morning show yesterday
that this is one of the seven legs as it
were
of the sedition stool
but here is bill barr describing
the three meanings that he that he had
and what his take on it was and the
reason why he [ __ ] resigned the
reason why he said nope i'm not gonna go
to federal prison
oh oh you guys you got oh you guys want
to commit federal crimes i see i'm not
doing that
i don't know bill barr was thinking why
wouldn't he think that why wouldn't bill
barr think i'm not going to commit
federal crimes what are you [ __ ] nuts
oh
you want to go to prison is that what
you people want to do well i'm not going
to go to prison
william barr is smarter than to put
himself in a situation where he has to
stand in front of a jury
in a federal court
of st to go to prison for seditious
conspiracy
[Laughter]
let's listen to bill barr but here's the
thing at the end of this tape
listen
to who believes what he says it's
beautiful
now just what i've i've been thr i've
had i had three discussions with the
president that i can recall one was on
november 23rd one was on december first
and one was on december 14th and i've
been through
sort of the give and take of those
discussions and in that context i made
it clear i did not agree with
the idea of saying the election was
stolen and putting out this stuff which
i told the president was [ __ ] i
respect attorney general barr
um
so i
accepted what he said was saying
so there it is
and there it is
i respect attorney general attorney
general barr
and i accept what he was saying it was
all [ __ ] she believed it she knew it
and not not now then
then folks in november and the beginning
of december before bill barr resigned
that's important
it's important the timing of this
that while they were stoking
the trump pumpers out there the
moglodites q anon
the proud boys the oath keepers as they
were preparing to violently overthrow
the government of the united states they
were trying to make sure the department
of justice would be on their side
and bill barr the attorney general at
the time
who is in charge of the department of
justice said no it's a bunch of [ __ ]
and donald trump's daughter ivanka
even as dumb as she is
knew that what bill barr was saying was
the truth
and believed him at the time
in the time that was most important
for these people to realize that it was
[ __ ] nonsense that he'd lost that he
won it was nonsense that he won
you [ __ ] lost dummy
why do you think they called georgia
why why do you think they called georgia
they were so desperate for just one
one just one they wanted just one person
to come out in front of a microphone and
said they'd won
bill barr the doj
the secretary of state in georgia
pennsylvania arizona think about this
think about this even if donald trump
would have been successful
in getting brad rathburger to find the
thousand four hundred whatever the [ __ ]
it was underneath his mattress
however many votes that he needed to win
by one
that's the craziest part that's the
that's the obvious intent there
even if brad rathersberger would have
would have broken the law and done that
and came out in front of a microphone
and said donald trump actually won
because last night underneath my
mattress i found 12 000 votes
that's actually what you would do like
if you were gonna like actually commit
election fraud you wouldn't look for the
amount of votes plus one like you would
you know do like 21
956 right like you'd want
you want to you want a few more
and you want a few [ __ ] more than
just the amount you need plus one
like
because even if you just find the amount
plus one there's gonna be a recount
right and that recount is it can have
some discrepancies so even though you
might think oh we found plus one
it might there might be five other votes
somewhere you know hidden in the count
that weren't exactly accurate before and
would [ __ ] you we seen that in arizona
with the [ __ ] goddamn cyber ninjas
they tried to recount several times and
joe biden ended up with more votes
but even if brad rathersberger in
georgia
would have done donald trump's bidding
at the time
even if brad rathersberger would have
done the crime and made sure that donald
trump was certified in georgia and the
state of georgia certified his vote even
with fraud
he still would have not won on january
6.
even with georgia
the electoral votes in the electors in
georgia certified for donald trump
officially
he still would have not won
think about that
he was so desperate not just to win
georgia because he thought that would
put him over the top he was so desperate
for someone anyone to get out in front
of a microphone
and say donald trump won
her there's fraud and no one would do it
but [ __ ] a bunch of seditionists
and that's how you know who the
seditionist is who they are the one
still claiming that donald trump won our
seditionist
and that's why this clip is so [ __ ]
important let's play it again
and again and again and again
now just what i've i've been i've had i
had three discussions with the president
that i can recall one was on november
23rd
one was on december first and one was on
december 14th and i've been through
sort of the give and take of those
discussions and in that context i made
it clear i did not agree with
the idea of saying the election was
stolen and putting out this stuff which
i told the president was [ __ ] i
respect attorney general barr
um
so i
accepted what he said was saying
play it for your uncle earl and your
aunt and edna
play it for your your sister
play it for all of them
and keep playing it
don't stop playing it
it's super super super important
it's super super important
that they see
what is the big lie
and what continues to be the big lie
let's go to some more tape
let's go do some more tape here let me
see i don't have gabe today to help me
through the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends or bonehead of the week but we're
gonna make it through
we're going to make it through um
might as touch um put out this video
there's a van rolling around washington
dc look look at this man growing my
washington d.c
we must stop this deal
and then we must continue
out
[Laughter]
oh it's called sedition it's called a
crime
oh my geared oh my gerd
well rachel bittikoffer post about the
hearing she says in case you missed it
donald trump is guilty af
he's guilty as [ __ ]
he's guilty as
[ __ ]
you rachel for your tweet you guys know
rachel's one of my uh favorite political
strategist
my favorite
i'm all hoping we can get rachel on for
some of the hearings for some commentary
next week during the daytime hearings if
we can
do let's see what else do we got here we
got a ton of uh
midas touch was tweeting last night
here's here's popock's tweet about uh
the uh the hearing and the coverage he
said proud to be on a panel with my
favorite fellow podcasters
to dissect what happened tonight with
the january 6 committee hearings and
here's a screenshot
of popock
in the room
with me gabe sanchez kfa
lee mcgowan politics girl and texas paul
and thank you for all of them
on joining us last night
it was quite fun afterwards i had a
great time before we had michael cohen
in the beginning uh adam barcaminco
ally we had um we had karen and we had
uh let's see who else did we had david
bender
i'm forgetting we had texas paul in the
beginning and then uh karen kfa karen
agnipolo and texas paul joined us during
this the the short break and then we had
them all in the end and we also had the
mizellas brothers the midas touch
podcast came on
at the at the end of the hearing the
three brothers joined us um they're
following the hearing um so thank you
for everyone joining
and giving us uh giving us the
opportunity to
uh to
to share with you the hearings
um one of the things in the after show
that a lot of people were talking about
was officer edwards
and when she's talking about
um brian sitnick
and
showing him
in her words
uh ghostly pale so i want to show that
that's a pretty stark little piece of
clip let's let's watch we were just
as the best we could we were just you
know grappling over
bike racks
and trying to hold them as quick as
possible
um
all of the sudden i see
movement
to the left of me
and i turned and it was officer siknik
with his head in his hands
and he was ghostly pale
um which i i figured at that point that
he had been sprayed
and i was
concerned my uh
you know cop
cop alarm bells went off
um
because if you get sprayed with
pepper spray
you're gonna turn red
he turned um just about as pale as the
sheet of paper
and so i looked back to see what had hit
him what had happened
and that's when i got sprayed in the
eyes as well
i was taken to be decontaminated by
another officer
but we didn't get the chance because we
were then tear gassed
so there you have where
carolyn edwards is uh describing
what happened to her
um but also
her evidence showing we were just
as the that officer
the officer that died that day
in the violent insurrection
um
what his situation was right before he
passed
um
we have a video that january 6 also put
out which was very
um oh boy it's um
it's hard to watch actually because it
just it gives you a sense of how violent
it was right there on the ground
even with just the audio i mean you see
the video but the audio is
almost excruciating because a lot of
videos that we've seen is from security
footage
and there's not a lot of audio
but what they did when they produced
this video here
is they pulled the audio from other
cameras
and it's bone chilling
that a member of congress anyone anyone
but a member of congress who was there
that day
would suggest that these were just
tourists
that somehow these people were patriots
and they weren't there to be violent
that they were there to just get into
the capital and talk to their talk to
their congressmen
they weren't there to hang mike pence
they weren't there to to
hog tie members of congress with zip
ties they weren't there to commit
violence
that's all [ __ ] in this video
anyone who watches this video and
afterwards says
otherwise is full of [ __ ]
absolute [ __ ] so i'm gonna play this
video it is it is almost 10 minutes long
so we'll play this video and when we
come back we'll watch a few more clips
from the hearing
and then we will go to
bonehead of the week so let's watch this
video right here
from the january 6
select committee
i am not allowed to say what's going to
happen today
because everyone's just going to have to
watch for themselves
but
it's going to happen
something's going to happen
pick
i hope mike is going to do the right
thing i hope so
i hope so
because if mike pence does the right
thing
we win the election all vice president
pence has to do is send it back to the
states to recertify
and we become president and you are the
happiest people
mike pence is going to have to come
through for us and if he doesn't
that will be a sad day for our country
because you'll never
take back our country with weakness
stepping off here
there's a crowd search heading east
we love trump
trump we have jail we love trump
[Music]
mike pence i hope you're going to stand
up for the good of our constitution and
for the good of our country and if
you're not i'm going to be very
disappointed in you i will tell you
right now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
get back ladies
we need backup
right here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
madam speaker
the vice president and the united states
senate
[Applause]
[Music]
but this is now effectively arrived
49 hours declaring it a riot
cruiser five to fifty feet by the cal
police one advisor trying to bridge and
get to the capitol
we're trying to make our way through us
[Applause]
oh thank you
[Music]
[Music]
they're requesting additional resources
on the east side as they've broken into
that window and they're trying to kick
it in
objection the chair declares the house
in recess pursuant to clause 12b of rule
one
my kids didn't have the courage to do
what should have been done to protect
our country and our constitution
giving states a chance to certify a
corrective set of facts
not the foreign or inaccurate ones which
they were asked to previously certify us
demands the truth
hey
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
we can't hold this we're gonna get too
many [ __ ] people here look at this
[ __ ]
we need an area for the housing members
they're all walking over now through the
tunnels
we're trying to hold the upper back we
are trying to hold you at the back now
we need to help the cars of the camper
i need poor support
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
be advised that capitol police is going
to start moving the resources inside all
right we're going to start the m4
officers first
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
h208 with four members the doors
barricade there's people plunging the
hallways outside we have no way out
advanced officers still remaining on the
house floor in the on the third floor to
use the subways themselves it's time to
evacuate so we can secure the members on
the other side coffee
it's up to us people now the american
people
one more time are you ready to do and
whatever it takes i'll lay my life down
if it takes
absolutely
that's why we showed up today
[Music]
get him up
back up
they were peaceful people these were
great people
the crowd was unbelievable and i
mentioned the word love the love
the love in the air i've never seen
anything like it
so there you have it
never seen anything like it the love in
the air he says
because that's all you heard on that
tape there was the love in the air right
i told you it was bone showing a lot of
people in the chat i weren't excited
about hearing it and seeing it but look
we cannot look away
this is a thing that we cannot do we
cannot look away from this and we can't
let other americans look away from this
this is so important
to what is going to happen to the rest
of our country from going forward
it is super important
that all americans understand what the
[ __ ] happened that day
and when marco rubio goes on sean
hannity's show
and he says oh
doesn't it tell you what they need a tv
producer for
if you watched the hearings last night
i mean i don't know what they thought it
was gonna be like like
like survivor and voting off the island
or some [ __ ]
but the only reason why they had a tv
producer is to make sure that the
[ __ ] clips were cued the way that
they needed to be cued
that's it that's the only reason
they just made sure that that that the
presentation that the january 6 select
committee was going to give
was going to go off
it was going to it was going to be well
put together and looked like they had
their [ __ ] together and they did
they did last night
they had their [ __ ] together
and that's the most important part here
is that they've got the evidence and to
to take all this evidence
i am not allowed to say what's going on
that we saw last night
all this evidence
and to pack it into
the few minutes that they packed it into
is absolutely incredible
it was crazy it was crazy
and we see more and more of these clips
i want to show you one thing
because this is
texas paul's reaction
i asked texas paul uh in our commentary
i said what is your reaction to
that video that we just show
the video that i just showed was at the
end of the very first part
of the hearing
and i asked texas paul in the break
because there was a 10 minute break
almost
right after that clip
i asked him i said
what did you think of that bone chilling
tape let me pull down the banner here so
you guys can see and here was texas
paul's reaction
to
that tape that video that they showed
i'm mad as hell i i just every time i
watch it i just
you know
chairman thompson talked about the will
of the people republicans don't give a
[ __ ] about the will of the people they
care about what they want and that's it
these stuff is could you live with
yourself if you had been at the capitol
and done that could you live with
yourself i'm kidding and that's and
that's the thing is they've always
framed it up as a tourist visit and i
appreciate you being mad as hell because
we need to continue that way and it
looks like that it looks like the uh
it's going to continue here so i'll give
you the last 30 seconds here paul i
can't hear i just wanna i mean i want to
throw this at you they had a documentary
filmmaker there to to to film this they
expected resistance
they thought that they were going to
have
the case to make that we lefties showed
up and they had to put us down
you know they they really thought that i
think that was because
pence had already communicated to trump
that he was not going to overturn this
election right if you remember the
conversation he had with dan quayle he
had made this decision right he was not
going to overturn this for trump trump
knew this when he gave that speech
and you know the the proud boys that
this was their last roll of the dice and
we did not show up so all they got was
hours and hours of footage i've said
this before but i really believe that
you talk about the meeting prior to on
january 5th
that's how they get to trump because
this i believe 100
that the people that they're indicting
are flipping like cirque the freaking
solei
i really believe that i mean i'm really
human being a former prosecutor i'm sure
she would agree with that
uh so there's texas paul's reaction to
that tape and i think all americans
should be mad as [ __ ] hell mad as
[ __ ] hell about that tape you should
be triggered you should be pissed
i've seen it in the comments here that
people are triggered by that video it
should get americans triggered
folks
rather buy a lime by delusion or
whatever
those people were there to take away our
democracy whether they knew it or not
they were there to take away our
democracy
um here is another part speaking of
taking away democracy and sedition um
here is another clip from the january 6
presentation and this one is very
important too
this one shows
because i've been yelling and screaming
about the proud boys and the oath
keepers for [ __ ]
months
you know we've had dakota adams and
stewart roach's estranged son and his
estranged wife tasha adams on the show
here on the tony michaels podcast and
you can find all those interviews on on
our youtube channel just go subscribe to
the youtube channel and you'll find
those there at tonymichaelspot click the
subscribe button and go to the oath
keepers playlist you'll see that there
just go to playlist tab you'll see the
oath keepers
playlist
but i've been yelling and screaming
about the proud boys and the oath
keepers i've said for months and months
and months and months and months
that the entire the entire
kobach talks about the seven legs
of the stool of the sedition stool here
one of them is eastman's memo
and overturning the election and martial
law and all this [ __ ] nonsense that
michael flynn that whackadoo has been
still talks about still to this day
talks about the martial law stuff
the proud boys and the oath keepers
were pivotal part of making sure that if
violence broke out that they were going
to arrest members of congress
they were going to be deputized under
martial law which donald trump would
declare
there was a qrf waiting across the river
which is a stash of weapons were waiting
across the potomac because they couldn't
have him in dc legally they were trying
to make it legal is what they were
trying to appear to make it
but the most important part is that
stewart rhodes was waiting for orders of
martial law
for that stash of weapons to be brought
across the potomac
that qrf
and that stash of weapons was not going
to be moved until martial law was called
until stewart rhodes was given the order
that there was martial law
why is that important well that's super
[ __ ] important
very very very
important and the reason why
is because if you think about the oath
keepers and the proud boys and the
meeting that they had
the night
before january 6 when enrique tario who
was not allowed to be in dc at the time
because of crimes that he committed
weeks before
they met the proud boys the oath keepers
and a few other groups met
and it seems suspicious that roger stone
who has direct contact with the
president of the united states at the
time donald trump switched his security
from the prowl boys to the oath keepers
and the reason why it's so significant
is because of that stash of weapons
because of that qrf folks
stuart rhodes had the authority over
that stash of weapons
he was the general of the oath keepers
he was the founder the leader that day
he was going to give the order to bring
those weapons across the river they had
them at the ready in case martial law
was declared well the only way for
stuart rhodes to know the moment when it
was declared is to have a back channel
and what better way to have a bat
channel than to have someone maybe a few
people standing right next to the back
channel on that day
why do you think why do you think joshua
james and brian ulrich
stewart rhodes lieutenants
were assigned to stodger rhone
as we call him here on the podcast
why do you think
what could possibly be the reason
that the prowl boys switched their
security to the or roger stone switched
to security from the proud boys to the
oath keepers
it was because of that stash of weapons
and because of the back channel that
they needed
for martial law
now i don't know if there's any evidence
because i'm sure they were using
burner phones
but hopefully the january 6 select
committee
serves us up some evidence
that that is the case and if they can't
hopefully the department of justice can
pull that in because we see
i suspect that they have that evidence
we see stewart rhodes and the oath
keepers being charged with seditious
conspiracy brian ulrich
admitting in court to the judge and his
plea
that yes he was in planning with stuart
rhodes the founder of the oath keeper to
make sure there was not a quote peaceful
chant transfer of power
and now we have enrique tario and his
proud boy lieutenants five of them
including tario
now charged in the superseding
indictment with the same charge of
seditious conspiracy
this is super important folks
and it's all hinged on this plan that
john eastman and donald trump cooked up
that mike flynn and the crack and sydney
powell and others perpetuated out into
the wackadoo universe
into the q anon
black hole
the decision of judge carter in
california on the eastman emails that no
it's not executive privilege because you
were committing crimes you were trying
to obstruct a a hearing an official
hearing
to certify an election
you're not protected under executive
privilege when you're trying to commit
crimes we know that from watergate
but here the january 6 select committee
put together a video about the proud
boys and the oath keepers
and what happened
when that when the infamous moment that
donald trump during the debate told the
proud boys to stand back
and stand by
let's take a listen here
my name is marcus childress and i'm an
investigative counsel for the select
committee to investigate the january 6
attack on the united states capital what
do you want to call them give me a name
give me a white supremacy
boys stand back and stand by after he
made this comment enrique theriot then
chairman of the proud boys said on
parlor standing by sir
during our investigation we learned that
this comment during the presidential
debate actually led to an increase in
membership from the prowl boys would you
say that proud boys numbers increased
after the standback standby common
exponentially i'd say
tripled probably with the potential for
a lot more eventually and did you ever
sell any stand back and stand by
merchandise
uh
one of the vendors on my page actually
beat me to it but i wish i would have i
wish i would have made a standback
standby shirt on december 19th president
trump tweeted about the january 6 rally
and told attendees be there will be wild
many of the witnesses that we
interviewed were inspired by the
president's call and came to dc for
january 6. but the extremists they took
it a step further they viewed this tweet
as a call to arms a day later the
department of justice describes how the
proud boys created a chat called the
ministry of self-defense leadership chat
in this chat the proud boys established
a command structure in anticipation of
coming back to dc on january 6. the
department of justice describes mr tario
coming into possession of a document
called the 1776 returns which describes
individuals occupying key buildings
around the united states capital the
oath keepers are another group that the
committee investigated you better get
your ass to dc folks this saturday
yeah if you don't there's there'll be no
more republic but we're not gonna let
that happen it's not even if it's it's
either president trump is encouraged and
bolstered strengthened to do what he
must do or we wind up in a bloody fight
we all know that the fight's coming the
oath keepers began planning to block the
peaceful transfer of power shortly after
november third election according to the
department of justice stuart rhodes the
oath keeper's leader said to his
followers that we were not going to get
through this without the civil war in
response to the december 19 to 2020
tweet by president trump the oath
keepers focused on january 6 in
washington d.c
in response to the tweet one member the
president of the florida chapter put on
social media the president called us to
the capitol he wants us to make it wild
the goal was for the oath keepers to be
called to duty so that they could keep
the president in power although
president trump had just lost the
election the committee learned that the
oath keepers set up quick reaction
forces outside of the city in virginia
where they stored arms the goal of these
quick reaction forces was to be on
standby just in case president trump
invoked the insurrection act did vo
keepers ever provide weapons to members
i'm going to climb the answer that i'll
put them in grounds
for uh
due process trials in footage obtained
by the committee we learned that on the
night of january 5th enrique tario and
stuart rhodes met in a parking garage in
washington d.c there's mutual respect
there
i think we're
we're fighting the same fight and i
think that's what's important
the committee learned that the oath
keepers went into the capitol through
the east doors and two stack formations
the doj alleges that one of the stacks
went into the capitol looking for
speaker pelosi although they never found
her as the attack was unfolding mr tario
took credit and documents obtained by
the department of justice mr tario said
in an encrypted chat made no mistake and
we did this
later on that evening mr tario even
posted a video which seemed to resemble
him in front of the capitol with a black
cape and the title of the video was
premonition
the evidence developed by the select
committee and the department of justice
highlights how each group participated
on the attack on the capitol on january
6th in fact the investigation revealed
that it was individuals associated with
the proud boys who instigated the
initial breach at the peace circle at 12
53 pm
within 10 minutes rioters had already
filled the lower west plaza
by two o'clock rioters had reached the
doors on the west and the east plazas
and by 213 rioters had actually broken
through the senate wing door and got
into the capitol building
a series of breaches followed
at 2 25 pm rioters reached the east side
doors to the rotunda
[Applause]
and then right after 2 40 pm riders
breached the east side doors near the
ways and means room
once the rioters infiltrated the capital
they moved to the crypt
the rotunda
the hallways leading to the house
chambers
and even inside the senate chambers
so there you have it
more evidence piling up against the oath
keepers and the proud boys
um
i i hope to have on
uh dakota adams again i've i've been in
communication with dakota adams you guys
know dakota adams is stewart rhodes the
guy with the eye patch the leader of the
oath keepers uh who was in charge of the
qrf the stash of weapons that they were
waiting on
martial law they're the insurrection act
it really was
you know we seen in the marjory taylor
green
uh ballot hearing where she was trying
to keep herself on the ballot
and what she was successful at um we
seen in that testimony that she couldn't
recall rather martial law
you know she spelled it wrong rather
martial law
where she was encouraging her not and
she was and they were and then they were
waiting for it they were waiting for the
call of the insurrection act so that way
that way they could say
that was actually happening what they
were trying to stop was an insurrection
and that that's kind of lost on folks
right the insurrection act now when
marcus childress here the the
investigator gives his testimony about
the insurrection act where they were
waiting for the qrf that's kind of lost
on folks because what what he's saying
is is that the oath keepers and the
proud boys and trump and his allies
were going to invoke a insurrection act
saying there was an interaction going on
and they had to stop it
so by causing an insurrection and this
is typical fascist gqp projection think
about think of think about everything
they do and everything they [ __ ] say
think about all of it
it's all projection
even on the even the idea that what they
would do is create a violent
insurrection on the capitol to stop the
certification of the vote so donald
trump could declare that there was an
insurrection happening on the other side
think about the projection thing about
the the modus operandi
of dark manga
yes yes you [ __ ]
you are the baddies
you are
the baddies
we're running out of time here we really
need to get to bonehead of the week i
have still a lot of tape that i want to
show you and i know we're going to show
some of it in the bonehead of the week
unfortunately i have to do bonehead of
the week all by myself today so we'll
see how that goes
gabe's out having fun i hoping he can
join us here in a few minutes now he was
texting me that he may he may join us
from his cell phone but stick around
right after the break right after the
break we will go to bonehead of the week
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy
by the time we reached dc we was 50
strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow
so we can circle the city again
here's
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the
live loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong
wipe your ass at least once a day
ears
tammy
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
the part of the show on fridays in the
second hour
you go through your vote on phone head
of the week that's right
into the week time
it's gonna be a little different just a
little different here
we do not have gabe sanchez with us it's
just me today for the bonehead of the
week
but we'll get through it we will get
through it i promise you we will get
through it here
if you want to vote for bonehead of the
week go over at the tony michaels pod
follow us on twitter you can also vote
for bonehead of the week on youtube
if you're on the tubes of you so don't
forget to subscribe to the youtube
channel you're definitely going to want
to subscribe to our youtube channel just
go to thetonymichaelspod
on youtube and twitter so that you can
vote for bonehead of the week because we
break it down here on the tony michaels
podcast every single friday so all you
new listeners out there because we do
have a few new wizards i really want to
explain
i want to explain how
how this bonehead of the week thing
works so on thursdays we put out the
bonehead of the week poll from the
boneheads of that week now sometimes
it's very difficult
meaning it's hard to choose because
there's so many [ __ ] boneheads to
choose from
there are a lot of boneheads out there
in the world that we live in today
now yesterday we put the bonehead of the
week pull out early because we had the
hearing
and we really weren't too far off here
right even with the evidence that we've
seen in the hearing
representative kevin mccarthy he was at
the top of the list there steve scalise
which you remember steve scalise talking
about how we didn't ban airplanes after
9 11.
because he's comparing airplanes to the
[ __ ] weapons that slaughtered 19
children in uvalde
blew their heads off decapitated them
literally parents were identifying these
children
from their dna and their tennis shoes
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] steve scalise
and then we have matt gatz and he's just
a reoccurring character here on the bone
end of the week why not
he's always been a bonehead always will
be we could put matt gatz on this list
every [ __ ] week you could do bonehead
of the day and matt gatz could be on
that son of a [ __ ]
but here's what we do for all the new
listeners we gather up the bone end of
the week we put up a poll for you to
vote on twitter or on youtube you can
vote either place and then on fridays in
the second hour of the show
we go through the bonehead of the week
so let's get started and go through the
bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the section of the show that
we call the bonehead of the week this
week's edition of bone end of the week
i'm alone this week because gabe is out
there having fun he deserves a lot of he
deserves to have a great uh weekend he's
he's having fun with some friends and
they're they they're they're celebrating
for a wedding that's upcoming
he worked really hard on all the
graphics for the hearing and for the
show he he does a lot of hard work that
that you get to see but you don't get to
see
the the sausage being made he works
really hard here so we appreciate gabe
so go show gabe some love over on
twitter go follow him and i am gabe
sanchez give him some hearts and like
some fire and tell him you missed him
for the bonehead of the week but here's
our contestants this week we have kevin
mccarthy steve scalise
and matt getz
oh what a cast of characters it usually
ended up being a bunch of white dudes on
these on these tiles that gave me gabe
made these tiles
even on his trip this weekend he's still
he's still working
but here is our
contestants for bonehead of the week and
you asked tony why
why oh why oh why oh why
are these the boneheads of the week well
kevin mccarthy was actually on the
bonehead of the week for a separate
reason
um and if i can pull if i'm gonna pull
it up here now again bear with me here
because normally what happens
is
i get i get gabe to talk
um while i'm looking up things
and today that's just
it's just not what's going to happen so
you have to bear with me for a minute
but we're going to get through this and
you remember the the video of kevin
mccarthy pointing and yelling on the
house floor um the other day yesterday
the day before i don't remember
i don't remember
um
but here here he is on
then this is an oan clip and i don't
know if oen's the only one that would
play this [ __ ]
but here he is on oan
um and he's in his press conference but
listen to who he blames
the insurrection on this is [ __ ] just
boneheaded at its best let's listen
you said both publicly and privately
after january 6 that you thought trump
for some responsibility for the attack
do you still feel like he was in any way
responsible for getting i've answered
that many times i thought everybody in
the country beared some responsibility
based upon what's been going on the
riots on the streets the others
you said both publicly and privately
after everyone in america is responsible
are you [ __ ] jit me
that's literally what this guy's gonna
say
is that everyone in america is
responsible well that's enough for be to
be on the bonehead of the week for me
really honestly now that's not the
that's not the actual reason why
we put him on bonehead of the week
but i think that's enough and i think
that's why uh you're gonna see today
kevin mccarthy is our winner here on
bone of the week
but that that is enough for me
now here's here's the other here's the
other thing about kevin mccarthy is
there was a video
that i'm going to show here in a bit
about kevin mccarthy
and
now that midas touch had
posted a clip of this so we're going to
watch here later why i think he actually
won the bonehead of the week poll why
you voted for him um so we'll we'll play
that here in just a bit but let's go
back to let's go back to our other
winners matt gatz and steve scalise matt
gatz
the reason why we put him on the
bonehead of the week and we played it
yesterday because we kind of we kind of
let you guys make the sausage yesterday
for this bone end of the week
matt gads is on here for the [ __ ] that
he said about jamie raskin of course
you know all these seditionists matt
gatz marjorie taylor green
kevin mccarthy the list goes on and on
and on here
um are absolutely freaking out about
what's going to be said
in the select hearing
they're terrified of it absolutely
terrified of it so much so that these
boneheads are saying crazy ass [ __ ] on
them on the floor of the house
i mean here they are here here here's
hoof foot green
sickle fanting
sycophanting
listen and why their due process rights
are being so fragrantly and horrifically
violated
and why their due process right she's
talking about the people who you seen in
the video just minutes ago
just minutes ago you've seen these
people in these videos
absolutely
tearing apart
of course of course they're getting due
process that's why they're sitting in
detention dummy
is because there's evidence against them
and they're being charged with crimes
it's not [ __ ] rocket science it
really is not hard to understand
why these people are sitting in
detention
it it really is
[ __ ]
just looney tunes that we have to sit
and listen to this nonsense and i want
to play another clip of matt gatt's
favorite person because that's in the
clip of
matt gatz talking about jamie raskin's
son committing suicide he's on marjorie
taylor green's show
it's what's happening
and the gross thing about the whole deal
is they're sitting there
yucking it up about jamie raskin
shouldn't be in congress because his
child had committed suicide just vile
gross [ __ ]
and then she goes on the floor of the
house to say this and most of all i want
to finish with this
there is something terrible happening in
this process and it's called defamation
of character
the president the 45th president of the
united states character is being defamed
and all of his staff and his family and
all republicans
everyone's reputation is being defamed
as lies are being told about all of us
and president trump
just for politics and it makes all of us
what the [ __ ] does that mean
think about her mindset here
she's saying she's saying what is
happening is defamation
now this is
of trump and his family now rather she
knew that ivanka trump was gonna her
testimony was gonna be [ __ ] played
last night
or not
i don't know i don't know if she knew
that or not i don't know she knew what
ivanka trump said in her testimony but
it's under oath you [ __ ] dummy
you're a [ __ ] idiot marjorie taylor
green if you think that ivanka trump
went
and said yes i agree with bill barr when
he says that the big lie is a bunch of
[ __ ]
that the big lie that donald trump told
and that rudy giuliani sidney powell
mike lindell steve bannon and the likes
perpetuated to create a violent
insurrection
on the capitol on the day of january 6
if you think that her going under oath
and giving her opinion about the big lie
that it's all a bunch of horse [ __ ] is
defamation you are a dumb [ __ ]
of course marjorie taylor green is that
makes me sick it absolutely disgusts me
if we're supposed to represent the
american people and we're supposed to do
a good job and and uphold this place
with honor
uh here here's marjorie taylor green
this is [ __ ] laughable this is
[ __ ] hilarious this is why you can't
parry these p parody these people hardly
you can't make satire of this how can
you make satire this here's martin
taylor green talking about honor are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] me get the [ __ ] out of
here with this [ __ ] and good for the
people we serve then we should be
truthful
but what's about to happen tonight is
not going to be truthful it's going to
be a political narrative and it's all
for politics and it is sickening yeah
okay
it is all for politics dummy and i said
tonight tonight is going to be good
folks
don't miss the coverage
because it's the truth it is all for
politics
yeah exactly
it's exactly all for politics and it
should be
we should play politics with this folks
that's what the whole [ __ ] january 6
select committee is for
benny
thompson said it in the beginning that
they wanted this
they
wanted a political [ __ ] body they
wanted a political investigation the
republicans had a chance for a
non-partisan non-bias
to congress
911 style commission and they said no
and the reason why they said no is
because they wanted to play politics
with january 6 and the results of the
evidence of january 6 they wanted to
play politics they felt like that was
probably the only survival mechanism
that they had was to play politics
so yeah it is politics and we should
play politics
and here's matt gatz in this video of
him i'm not going to play the whole
thing because it's [ __ ] gross it's
really [ __ ] gross these two [ __ ]
sick sons of [ __ ] sitting here
talking about jamie raskin's
child
committing suicide and somehow that
should impede him on doing his job you
you dirty vile sick gross [ __ ]
what i worry about with raskin and all
seriousness you know um in all
seriousness you [ __ ] you are not a
[ __ ] serious person and no one takes
your associate a lot mr venmo around
that trauma piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
naturally or or even rationally
associate maybe so and what i maybe so
i'm not even i'm i'm done i'm done but
i'm not even gonna go go forward anymore
that [ __ ] garbage [ __ ] them
pieces of [ __ ] absolute trash
trash they are
but what are you gonna do
well let's see let's let's move on who
else we get oh steve scalise
steve scalise
you watched him uh
talk about how
oh
oh
airplanes banned we we we didn't ban
airplane maybe we should ban airplanes
after nine uh maybe we we should
regulate
what a [ __ ] idiot you guys remember
this clip
do you remember this
i'm steve scalise
let me see if i can find it here again
normally yeah my co-host gabe sanchez is
talking while i'm looking here it is
looking for clips actually gabe had a
tweet here about it
let's let's pull up gabe's tweet here he
said with a
uh it was a
con
conversation about connecting the dots
how we can try to figure out if there's
signs we can see to stop the next attack
from happening and he's talking about
gun violence right and he's talking
about he's trying to compare it to the
911 attack steve scalise is a victim of
gun violence and he still runs through
the point like you run straight through
it here now let's watch here let's pull
this up here
um here he is talking about banning
airplanes after 911. he doesn't get it
problems that were creating those
attacks
and airplanes were used that day
as the weapon to kill thousands of
people and to inflict terror on our
country okay number one and we mentioned
this the other day number one
you [ __ ] idiot
airplanes like airplane manufacturers
don't [ __ ] build airplanes to kill
people
okay number one never [ __ ] won
scalise you dumb son of a [ __ ] have you
ever went to a baseball field and just
had airplanes shot at you steve scalise
you stupid bastard this is a [ __ ] guy
who is a victim of gun violence the son
of a [ __ ] almost died
and he's still in the pocket of the nra
the nra paid him to come out and say
this [ __ ] into a microphone i said it
the nra paid this [ __ ] to say
this vile [ __ ]
steve scalise did not have airplanes
hurdle that has hurtled at him in a
baseball field
that's not what happened
he was shot by a gun but listen to what
he says about regulating airplanes
even though airplanes aren't designed to
kill people they're actually designed to
keep people safe like they actually
build airplanes engineer airplanes they
have federal regulations on airplanes
that we
we put in place we the people vote for
elected officials who make sure that the
[ __ ] airplanes that we ride on are
[ __ ] regulated so they're safe for
humans and don't kill us
you stupid [ __ ]
there wasn't a conversation about
banning airplanes there was a
conversation about connecting the dots
how can we try to figure out
if there are signs we can see to stop
the next attack from happening
oh my god yeah there is a conversation
about it yep exactly
no one no one is saying there's not one
[ __ ] public official that i can find
and i don't even know that there's one
person that you would you would talk to
in this country that would believe
that gun manufacturers are going to stop
manufacturing guns right
i don't i and we're gonna ban all guns i
don't think there's one person that
believe there may be some people that
want to do that but they pray even the
people who want to do that probably
believe that that won't happen
in our country there's i mean it's hard
to imagine that there would be no guns
there's there's more guns and there are
people right now so it's hard to believe
that that would ever be a
a future that would come to fruition and
anyone even people who want that
probably wouldn't believe it if you told
them that
because the evidence is stacked against
you
but he says
we we tried to figure out a way to make
sure that this wouldn't happen again
yeah you dumb [ __ ]
yeah we put all kinds of regulations in
place to make sure that a person can't
use a [ __ ] plane to kill thousands of
people
think about that because they always
blame it on the person it's not the gun
it's the person well if it's not the
plane and it's the person we sure as
hell put a hell of a lot of regulations
to make sure we know who the [ __ ] is on
an airplane so that they can't use it as
a weapon to kill a bunch of innocent
people you dumb son of a [ __ ]
pluck your head out of your ass steve
scalise and understand what you're
saying what you're saying here you're
running straight through the point
is yes most americans realize that we're
not going to be able to [ __ ] stop the
gun manufacturers from manufacturing
guns and we won't be able to ban all
firearms
most americans probably 99.9
would agree with that fact whether you
like it or not
i mean [ __ ] we pretty much
we we pretty much did away with smoking
in this country but we didn't ban the
manufacturers from from from [ __ ]
getting cigarettes did we no or from
manufacturing cigarettes did we know and
cigarettes killed hundreds of thousands
of people
we just made it to where they couldn't
advertise in certain ways they couldn't
attract certain audiences you know like
young children to start smoking or 18
year old crazy ass 18 year olds to go
buy guns on a credit card to go
slaughter 19 children at a school
this is really [ __ ] dumb stupid [ __ ]
that he is talking about here because
he's actually making the argument this
is more of this projection-ass [ __ ]
let's listen
and some people might have thought that
wasn't possible
and yet because congress came together
and focused on the root cause of the
problem
thank god we have been able to stop
other attacks on our homeland and there
and ran more into the point by admitting
that yes you got to get to the root of
the problem which the problem that we're
talking about here steve scalise is the
[ __ ] gun it's the gun it's the gun
it's the gun you dumb sons of [ __ ]
it is the gun
so thank you to our co-host gabe sanchez
for posting that video so i had it up
and ready
we also have some dishonorable mention
in alphacuts
you guys know
you guys know here on the bonehead of
the week we always have a problem here's
the problem that we have with bone of
the week we fill in the bone of the week
these three people and then at the last
minute there emerges more
bone heads
more boneheads appear
and
there was a lot of boneheads there was
jack del rio this week there was tucker
carlson there was marjorie taylor green
there was marco rubio
but the alpha guck of the week went to
mr sean hannity and i believe the reason
why we agreed to have sean hannity as
the alpha cuck of the week is because of
us
of
marco rubio on his show but actually you
know what uh
let's see here let's go back here
uh i think i have gabe sanchez holy moly
you actually did join me for bonehead of
the week i joined you i told you i'd be
here i'm you know
somewhere are you did you no no did you
flee to some mountain top away from i
had to for my own safety i had to go to
uh undisclosed location are you camping
or what the hell is going on out
there look i can't give you details just
know that i'm safe i am
uh
just want to let everyone know you know
thank you so much for for
tuning in last night i i can't tell you
how grateful tony and i am for the
people who who stayed through and
watched the the defending of democracy
happen um and a big thank you to the
myself brothers and minus touch and all
of our our pundits that came on and gave
their gave their expertise and what they
had to say about
the hearings and everything that
happened that had to happen um you know
super grateful and thankful for everyone
that listened that that came in
that chatted
uh thank you thank you so much um but
yeah i figured i would i would i would
jump in during bonehead of the week i
mean i can't not you know that's i can't
break the can't break the uh
the the
the uh
the thing that we have going on here on
friday i'm blanking on what i'm trying
to say but i know well here's the thing
here i'm higher altitude
right well that the scenery is much
better there than in than in your
grandma's basement yeah i don't know if
people know this but that that room that
gave that look at that look at that look
at the view here here let me put it on
the full screen look at this
look at this view that gabe sanchez is
oh my god
oh my god everyone be jealous of of gabe
sanchez here on the bonehead
we should have made we we should have
made gabe the bonehead of the week
because he didn't invite us all to come
where he's at um gabe i want to tell you
real quick uh why we have you because i
don't know how long we have you but i
want to thank you you were thanking
everyone else but you did you did such a
great job with all the
all the design all the effort that you
put in there's so much stuff in the
background that no one saw with all the
spreadsheets and all the documents that
we created to to make sure that the show
went off um all the links that we had
all all the chats that we had going on
during the last several weeks to get
this production off the ground and you
did a great job and i don't i don't know
if people know this but you were kind of
at a bachelor party last night and uh
you know they didn't really see that the
the strippers in the background but you
know
we we kind of we kind of maybe you know
maybe next time we'll get a yeah
yeah next time in the background i mean
i was i was tuckered away in a corner
and everyone else was outside kind of
you know having beers and drinking
meanwhile yeah yeah i was like gotta
stay focused gotta watch what's going on
here you know um so i'm super grateful
that we were able to to to pull that off
what we did um
and again so thankful for everyone who
came in and
chatted with us and shared what we were
doing and in the hearing so i'm
i'm uh i'm super excited for monday you
know we got a second hearing that will
happen during the morning during our
normally uh scheduled show so i'm very
pumped about that one yeah you're going
to be up early in the morning for that
one
yeah yeah yeah really very early
yeah
still it's still i mean it's our normal
it's our normal time isn't it
well i mean it's it's
it starts a couple hours earlier than we
start and then it's going to continue on
into our show right i'm not sure exactly
how we're going to do it we'll we'll
figure that out probably on the flight
speaking on the fly you were even
creating art yesterday while the hearing
was happened you were
you were you were having a nice beer and
trying to get the graphics um for a
couple things that we didn't expect
right yeah i didn't you know we
did not have the stuff ready for uh for
nick the documentary filmmaker and also
caroline edwards the uh capitol police
officer but we got it and we had their
had their name plates ready to go so
that everyone knew who was actually
giving their witness testimony
um
it's seven my time uh yeah seven your
time man mj's pointing out that yeah mj
says no at 7 00 am you're done sorry
gabe guess i'm getting up earlier than
that yeah well it happens it happens
early early to rise
yeah earlier you know just got rise and
grind but this is what we do but you
know tony this is it this is it and we
are in i was just going through uh sean
hannity can you stick around real quick
uh because i want to show this video
yeah just just just uh just a couple
seconds here i want to show this video
marco rubio and i want to get your
reaction uh to what he says about the
production since we're talking about
production anyways let's listen to this
well if this was a real congressional
hearing and not a kangaroo court and not
a circus and not a made for tv
production and an infomercial for their
political purposes those are the
questions they would be asking that's
exactly what they would be asking it
would be a review of why didn't capitol
police why didn't the sergeant-at-arms
take advantage of these resources that
were available that's what you would be
focused on but they're not going to be
focused on that this is a you know i
mean they move this thing to prime time
they hired a producer to put it on this
is not a fact-finding mission this is a
two-hour free documentary sponsored by
virtually every major network in america
except for this one that's willing to
give it airtime the only good thing
about it is most americans aren't going
to watch this garbage they i mean people
already know what happens so yesterday
so yesterday oh last night we seen that
that the producer was just to make sure
it all went off right just like we were
doing last night with our production
with all the guests that we had for the
commentary we were just making sure that
everything worked and everyone was there
the mics were working the film was was
up when it needed to be up then i made a
few mistakes you noticed them some
didn't but you notice them because you
pay attention to the details but sean
hannity last night apparently did not
even go to commercial is what i'm
hearing he didn't even go to commercial
because he didn't want to lose his
audience to people who might go hear the
truth and marco rubio here
he could have been one of our boneheads
and certainly the alpha cuck or the dm
but he he talks about the production but
i find it funny that he's on the show
right he's on sean hannity's show and
last night during the hearing like he's
like oh this is all a documentary it's
all made up it's all abuse [ __ ] no one's
gonna watch this trash sean hannity was
a key piece of evidence
in the [ __ ] hearing where they talk
about him and kaylee mac and amy talking
about how do we convince donald trump
just to go away like it's it's hilarious
it is serious it is hilarious i mean we
had already you know and the last thing
i'll say before i go is we had already
seen liz cheney read out the text
messages from
those fox news correspondents to mark
meadows and now
she's like yeah i've got thousands here
that i can even do and let's play one
from sean hannity to kaylee mcinney and
really show how even more people inside
the administration were having
communication with people who were the
the correspondents at fox seems weird
that they should have that type of uh
kind of direct line or insight or or say
or influence on how it's handled but
i think it's funny by the fact that that
sean hannity again you know he didn't
want to lose anyone and we joked about
it like what would happen if he was
plain if they ever even played the
hearing right and it would have happened
it would have been sean hannity hearing
his name and seeing the text messages
the literal receipts put on screen and
they're like oh let's go to commercial
that would have been the only time he
would want to go to commercials right
and here here it is here it is he says
in the text message 2k magnate the
number one thing to try to stop no more
crazy people he says is no more stolen
election talk in other words he's
admitting he's admitting gabe that it's
all [ __ ] it's all [ __ ] [ __ ]
and and marco rubio who says it's all a
sham and a fake in a kangaroo court
i highly doubt that any of the
depositions they played last night from
people like ivanka trump bill barr
miller like these are people who are
under oath and have to give testimony or
their so i wouldn't say that it's all
false because it's 100 percent true
unless of course those people want to be
uh
you know caught in a lie right yeah they
would commit perjury they can make
verdicts too so anyway i just wanted to
come on here and say get back get get
back to uh setting up your campsite for
your camping up there so that you can
stay away from all all the trouble that
you've caused in the last few weeks with
your production and thank you again for
all the production
that you put in for the hearing and
we'll see you soon my friend don't don't
have too much fun this i mean have fun
just yeah well you know what have a lot
of fun i'll be ready to go have my
sunday night sleep to get early as as i
was just pointing out at 7 00 my time
yeah well and don't do any don't do
anything that donald trump would do well
you know what do a lot of stuff that
donald trump jr donald trump jr would do
do what don jr would do this weekend
gabe do it thanks a lot my friend you
have a good one we'll talk to you soon
thank you very much
holy moly we had gabe sanchez join us
from the mountaintop
up all the way from the mountaintop
thank you gabe for joining us i was
hoping he could cut in and have a good
view from where he was at he sent me a
couple pictures earlier and i was hoping
he couldn't here's these text messages
that we were talking about earlier from
kaylee mcinning
and sean hannity because you know he's
our alpha guck
of the week
um i i want to point out a few more
things here and there the reason why is
because kayla kaylee mcenany's response
now remember gailey magnani is the one
who was
lying out in the public as the press
secretary when he said no more crazy
people to her she said yes a hundred
percent it's hard to see here but yes a
hundred percent she says and then he
says no more election talk or no more
stolen election doc she says i love that
thank you this is our playbook
now
it's not the playbook
to to
to to win the election right she's not
saying here
um this is the playbook to win the
election and steal the election have a
an insurrection that's that's the
playbook that happened on january 6.
this is after january 6.
this is when he went out on milan and
said oh i love you people you people are
so nice
and so great and we love you but go home
remember the video and i think we're
going to have a few
different versions of that video in
these hearings but this is after that
when this guy was delusional when they
were talking about the 25th amendment
i mean even in these texts look look
here look in these texts it says it says
yes impeachment in 27th amendment or
25th amendment is real
in other words yes people are talking
about 25th in him yes we need to get him
to believe that people are talking about
2015
his ass
that is the thing that we need to do to
convince him to shut the [ __ ] up and go
away because that's what they were
trying to do because they knew it was
all live they knew it was all [ __ ]
they knew had gone too far
and that they did not want him [ __ ]
touching anything they didn't want him
to be alone with government
he would grab it by the [ __ ] is what
they were scared of
so that's why sean hannity
he's our alpha cuck because not only was
he cucking for trump but then he was he
was cucking to get him to shut up and
then last night he couldn't even air it
wouldn't even aaron what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
speaking of [ __ ] uh you heard last
night also that a representative scott
perry
scott perry was one of the
representatives that was seeking a
pardon apparently um liz cheney talks
about it
uh in the in the hearing
let me see if i can pull the video up
where she talks about scott perry and
the members of congress and i think this
is very significant and the reason why i
believe this is so significant is
because she says that they were lined up
lined up
to for pardons like this this is this is
some [ __ ] that needs to be outed and
then i said it earlier on in the episode
i think that whatever that list is of
people who are seeking pardons
i believe
i believe that that list of people who
were seeking pardons
is the expulsion list right i mean why
would you seek a pardon him
if not to if not
if not to circumvent any crimes you've
already committed that you know you've
committed
and here's liz chaney last night talking
about scott perry
and trying to get pardons
as you will see
representative perry contacted the white
house in the weeks after january 6
to seek a presidential pardon
multiple other republican congressmen
also sought presidential pardons for
their roles in attempting to overturn
the 2020 election
as you will see
representative perry contacted the white
house in the weeks after january 6th to
seek a presidential pardon
yep yep yep yep play it over and over
and over and over again folks
do not let up on this this is super
important that we
we definitely hear that over and over
again and that's why scott perry and
maybe we should have like an you know
whole list of dishonorable mention and
maybe just maybe in these hearings we
will find out that list of dishonorable
mentions
that will make their way
to
evidence inside the committee
about
who was the members of congress that
were seeking pardons that's what i want
to know
not just scott perry here but the other
members of congress so that's why he was
our
dishonorable mention this week but i
want to go boy i want to go to the
winner
the winner is kevin mccarthy
for bonehead of the week
um not just for his little tirade that
he had on the floor the other day losing
his [ __ ] mind
but more about the evidence that they
provided last night and liz shane liz
janey darth vader jr you guys know that
i'm i'm not a fan
necessarily
of liz cheney what i mean by that is i
actually don't think she's this
this person who is
who is
100 for democracy and here's why she's
not voting she didn't vote for voting
rights she doesn't want women to have
bodily autonomy in this country she's
not for your liberty
but the enemy of your enemy sometimes
can be your friend and right now liz
cheney's goal is to destroy trumpism and
to destroy the big line because i
believe that liz cheney knows deep down
inside her black heart her cold black
heart if she has a heart i don't know
maybe her father gave her what was
remaining of his
inside her cold black heart i don't know
maybe just maybe
liz cheney knows
that if trumpism survives in her party
her party is done
and she wants to be the leader of her
party she wants to regain her party the
party of darth vader of dick cheney her
father
she is darth vader jr but last night boy
let me tell you something uh and texas
paul said it last night
on the the
the remainder
uh the after show of the commentary of
the hearing texas paul said that she was
going to napalm kevin mccarthy and here
is a preview of how she absolutely
destroys him you will hear that leaders
on capitol hill begged the president for
help
including republican leader mccarthy who
was quote scared who was quote
scared
no [ __ ] to give with liz cheney on
kevin mccarthy she doesn't she has no
[ __ ] sympathy for that son of a [ __ ]
who at first was scared and who said yes
we need to stop this [ __ ] he even went
on air
on tv
live saying we need to stop this [ __ ]
that he had contacted the president to
stop this [ __ ] and liz cheney saying
he's scared and he turned even on her
when she said the truth
and called multiple members of president
trump's family after he could not
persuade the president himself
not only did president trump refuse to
tell the mob to leave the capitol
he placed no call to any element of the
united states government to instruct
that the capital be defended
he did not call his secretary of defense
on january 6. he did not talk to his
attorney general he did not talk to the
department of homeland security
president trump gave no order to deploy
the national guard that day
so there you have it there is the reason
why kevin mccarthy is the bonehead of
the week
so everybody let's give
oh kevin mccarthy his due you voted for
him we break it down
and let's give old kevin mccarthy his
due here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
kevin mccarthy the bone end of
the week
thanks for joining us for bonehead of
the week i appreciate it and i'm glad
that gabe sanchez
did not break the streak and he joined
us for bonehead of the week again go
give him some love go go follow gabe on
twitter at i am gabe sanchez talk about
give him give him some love about the
campsite that he's got but follow us at
tonymichaelspod where you can vote for
bone end of the week
every single week on thursday usually
thursday evening you can also vote on
youtube so don't forget to subscribe to
the youtube channel
at tony michael's pod
follow us on youtube and twitter and
vote every single week for bonehead of
the week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what what a fantastic fantastic
um
presentation we had last night with all
the great guests for the hearing i want
to again thank all the guests uh michael
cohen politics girl texas paul
uh we had david bender we had karen
agnipolo michael popock now from legal
af but i also want to thank the mizellas
brothers from midas touch you guys know
him from the midas touch podcast and all
the work they do over at midas touch um
we are proud partners of the midas touch
network
we broadcast every single weekday live
on youtube twitter twitch and we
simulcast from midas touch facebook page
but i really appreciate and thank um
everyone for being there last night and
also the mizellas brothers for
entrusting me
with the great responsibility of making
sure that that production and that
commentary came straight to you and that
you were able to watch the january 6th
select hearings i really we worked hard
on that now gabe the brothers all the
people who came and commentated uh it
was a it was a group effort and i really
appreciate you joining us last night
make sure that you set your reminders
we're going to be sending out a monday's
hearing uh sometime this afternoon so
you will see
that hearing appear um as a link on
midas touch youtube channel to where you
can set your reminder so don't forget to
be watching for monday's hearing the
very next hearing
and i think that's how we should do it
is go from hearing to hearing to hearing
is monday is the hearing monday morning
so be looking for that link and we will
start just the same way we did with the
other one we will start an hour early
and we will do commentary in the hour
before if there is a break we will do
commentary during the break and then we
will do commentary afterwards so make
sure to pay attention where that link is
go to mydusttouch and follow them uh
again follow us on twitter
tonymichaelspod follow me at
thetonymichaels and follow gabe sanchez
at i am gabe sanchez we will be tweeting
out that link
now for you guys to follow and set your
reminder for also download every single
episode of the tony michaels podcast on
apple spotify and google the best of the
week this week
i'm going to play parts of the hearing
uh the commentary from the hearing for
you guys i believe that is the best
content that we have this week is some
of that commentary so you will hear
tomorrow on apple spotify and google you
will find that the best of the week
which we post every saturday is going to
be parts of the hearing commentary and
then on sunday on sunday on all the
directories apple spotify google your
favorite directory that you download
your podcast you will find bonehead of
the week in and of itself so download
that there don't forget to subscribe to
the youtube channel and don't miss any
any of our episodes or any of our clips
and even if you do if you're subscribed
you can go watch them there you can go
watch them there
and come to youtube and participate in
the super chat um today sorry i didn't
get to the chat i i know you guys are
giving a lot of love out there
um uh
even someone's even mentioning um midas
robin is giving a shout out to brett
mizellis it's his birthday so you might
want to go
go to twitter and wish brett my zealous
a happy birthday so sorry i didn't get
to the chat i had a lot of stuff going i
didn't i didn't have my my co-host today
he's out having fun
so thank you gabe thank you midas touch
thank you to all the commentators and
you guys
spread those clips around like herpes
around the interwebs like i always say
spread them around like herpes
have a great weekend be safe and we'll
see you monday monday morning we will be
early on the podcast remember we will be
broadcasting at our normal time but we
will be early for the hearing so join us
early for the hearing don't forget to
find that link
have a safe weekend
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking